les chérit les 5
alors n'ayez pas peur après bien sûr que
le public a une grosse place oui mais à
dire que ces cinq là c'est sûr et après
les autres toutes les autres petits
chouchous semble baisser envers ans mais
en tout cas c'est le choix du public
il ya ceux qui veulent voir absolument
l'année prochaine après y avoir réglé
des comptes publics bien là peut-être
qu'ils vont vouloir arrêter
est ce que dit la vérité skrela qui se
posent la question tout ce que tu déjà
qu'ils disent moi l'année prochaine
peut-être ça va être l'année en plus tu
pas sûr d'aller au bout de l'aventuré
avec vous quand même 7 10 lors de
l'aventuré va s'arrêter à ça du bol de
ses clients alors je tiens à vous dire
il y aura pas de prime n'aura pas de
prime 2 pour la dixième année en disant
10% plus mal on a déjà attention on
numéro 5 christine kelly
il fait partie des cinq ma chérie oui ça
a été mal mais c'est l'ordre social vote
s'il vous plaît est ce qu'on veut dire
que mes traits de 12000 oui quand même
c'est non en quatrième position
est ce que les gens celle ou celui que
les gens veulent revoir l'année
prochaine absolument en quatrième
position c'est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est incroyable raymond qui est déjà
parce que rémy slama qu'à toi aussi
c'est avant tout un pote à raymond que
voilà c'est un chauffeur-livreur c'est
un pote à moi en fait je vais demander
de venir autour de la table et il s'est
avéré être très très bon et répond je
fais un énorme bisou n'est pas pris à
l'envers c'est mon frère nom n'a pas du
tout pris à l'envers note
c'est le vrai classement je le dis et
comme quoi c'est à dire à la perception
du public aussi mais est importante et
c'est vrai que christine et raymond 13
5e et 4e et en 3e position
je me suis sûr mais c'est la force de
l'habitude fait partie des meubles
c'est vraiment bravo
attention numéro 2 des chroniqueurs
invoquer kelly vélo vénissieux père
robert à je suis père choqué mais ça me
fait plaisir
alors ça fait plaisir pour vous
franchement ah bon c'est bon ça me fait
plaisir c'est top
s'ils ont un cellulaire c'est le
tremblement de terre fait partie de la
bande aussi we may be caméra sûrement
focus d'autres disent allez découvrir
celui que vous avez classé numéro 1
déjà les quatre là vous voulez
absolument les revoir l'an prochain pour
la dixième saison en ahl vous êtes
contents les cathos pas été très choqué
si vous aviez l'intention peut-être de
partir a dit sue s'est pas affolé quand
on est une bande en première position
avec 14% des voix c'est sa taille
attention les voies le foyer où la
première scène
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
annonce que tu resteras aussi ça prouve
bien que ce classement n'est pas truquée
forcément sinon louise de pas alors je
vous le dis les audi fait un travail
formidable
aussi voilà c'est un classement voilà
c'est les 5 qui on voulait revoir
absolument des prochaines et c'est vrai
que mathieu c'est tout cas extrêmement
puissant sur les twitter voilà vous êtes
le deuxième animateurs du paf sur
twitter avec combien d'abonnés
bien vu devenu ennemi ou autre mais oui
c'est le numéro deux animateurs celle où
les sept premiers oui merci s'il vous
plaît romain de rome 1-2 non mais
mathieu numéro deux il est passé devant
tout le monde
ça a joué aussi mais franchement mathieu
vous êtes numéro un il forcé
[Applaudissements]